صلاه الفجر
تقام على الساعه الخامسه والربع
وصلاه العشاء على الثامنه والنصف بدءا من
غد باذن الله
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
[Silence]
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على رسوله الكريم وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده عبده ورسوله
اللهم صل وسلم وبارك على نبينا محمد وعلى
اله واصحابه اجمعين
اما بعد
ان شاء الله تعالى
مسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم arrival مدينه
[Arabic recitation]
بني زهره
بنو زهره
and name isقن
was before you was
manن
جاهليه بني زهره
المقداد
المقداد بن الاسود رضي الله عنه المقداد
بن اسود
was
days was
بدر
ابن حجر رحمه الله
in
someone was backle
prop
all
and said
of them on
their names exactly for
ابن
الله عنه was very brave courageous
صلى الله عليه وسلم
رضي الله عنه
مدين
المقداد ابن الاسود
اهل الصفه
small
صلى الله عليه
‏was
faqجد
الاقصى and they built a small canopy
because they have enough to cover the
entire ceiling. ‏It was open air except
for the very front had a canopy that the
would stand under you know for
and during and so forth so that he be
able to lead
and then when the changed directions to
this is about 16 mon after
direction of the became
direc
was
takeف
andيره
was اهل
‏can
you
‏the
po
comp of all the comp they the difficult
time matter it was
so hung and would days without a
f
‏Some of them would fall down and would
actually consciousness during
because they were unable to
malnurishment
through all because they were so hungry.
يقول المقداد رضي الله عنه اقبلت انا
وصاحبان لي وقد ذهبت اسماعنا وابصارنا من
الجهد يعني من القله من قله الاكل فجعلنا
نعرض انفسنا على اصحاب رسول الله صلى الله
عليه وسلم فليس احد منهم يقبلنا
يعني
لقله ذات اليد ما في حدا منهم يستطيع انه
يقبلهم يعني يتولى امرهم
المقداد
مدينه
هجره
مهاجرين
‏propoured
and
we toess
our difficult state in you know so many
to
‏was time
and
comp take
noticنا
بنا الى اهله
فاذا ثلاثه اعنز
اعنز جمع عنزه ثلاث عنزات
موجودات عنده صلى الله عليه وسلم فقال
النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم احتلبوا هذا
اللبن بيننا
صلى الله عليه
‏out of desperation out of hunger
and he took us even though he himself
was in a state where many days he would
ask for food and there was nothing in
the house but he took them he tried to
find them solu
he said so the prop
took us to
qu
‏And he had three little goats.
Three little goats that you know could
could yield some milk. ‏Now if people
are the goats are starving right and was
difficult time
go
the prop
said
goats meaning every milk goats give me a
por and then divide the rest of the
three the rest of it up in equal
portions amongst
قال فكنا نحتلب فيشرب كل انسان منا نصيبه
ونرفع ونرفع للنبي صلى الله عليه وسلم
نصيبه قال فيجيء من الليل اي النبي صلى
الله عليه وسلم فيسلم تسليما لا يوقظ
نائما ويسمع اليقضان
‏So it was every day
and his two companions went and milk
these three little goats and whatever
portion they had they cut it into
and they put a for the prophet
and they divided up the rest of the
three pors. ‏Now what they would do is
they would put it in a kind of pot right
made out of pottery made out of play and
they would place it because at night the
prophet
was wake up for
he would come into the and pray pray
and so what they would do is they would
milk it put it in little they would
cover it up and they would set it in the
place where he comes
‏would
inleur
con
someone
‏could
notur
someone
would come at find
would uncover wouldayسلم
سلم تسليما لا يوقظ نائما ويسمع اليقضان
قال ثم ياتي المسجد فيصلي ثم ياتي شرابه
فيشرب
makeلا
uncover finding
about here
grown men right grown strong back
‏ing of hunger
they have little goats and this is all
they have all day how much could these
goats possoule
of a coule of sips a coule of mouthfuls
that's it and so he would come would
pray then he turn to whatever that was
and would drink it
قال فاتاني الشيطان
شيطان
فاتاني الشيطان ذات ليله وقد شربت نصيبي
فقال يعني الشيطان قال له محمد ياتي
الانصار
فيتحفونه ويصيب عندهم ما به حاجه الى هذه
الجرعه
فاتيتها فشربتها
شيطانفونه
food he's enjoying himself
telling him feeding him you know of
everything
‏So he doesn't really need these few
gulps of milk.
الشيطان
فلما ان وغلت في بطني يعني وصلت الجرعه
الى بطنه
وعلمت انه ليس اليها سبيل مش عارف يطلعها
قال ندبني الشيطان فقال ويحك ما صنعت
اشربت شراب محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم فيجيء
فلا يجده فيدعو عليك فتهلك
شيطان
notice of the friends which is drankit
المقداد
my
back to and
said what you
come now and find
‏you and
you have life
and so
وعلي شمله الشمله مثل هذه كانوا يلفونها
على رؤسهم عشان غبار الصحراء وكذا قال
وعلي شمله فاذا وضعتها على قدمي خرج راسي
واذا وضعتها على راسي خرج قدماي وهو يعني
نايم على الارض وجعل لا يجيئني النوم
‏upover
and said cover my head would come out my
feet and my head would stick out and if
anyone of us has been very terrified you
know that one symtoms
‏andoldableyle
صاحباي فنام
ولم يصنع ما صنعت
قال فجاء النبي صلى الله عليه
‏minutover my feet are com minut cover
my feet my head is com
over my two friend
asleep because
he said so the prop
into the
فسلم كان يسلم andلام
as
ثم اتى المسجد فصلى
السلام
ثم اتى شرابه
فكشف عنه
شمله
فكشف عنه فلم يجد فيه شيئا
صلى الله عليه
الصلاه
فقلت الان يدعو علي فاهلك
فقال
اللهم اطعم من اطعمني واسق من سقاني
اللهink
صلى الله عليه وسلم دعاء
دعاء wasn'tطان
whisper
was
قال فعمدت الى الشمله فشددتها علي واخذت
الشفره فانطلقت الى الاعنز ايها اسمن
فاذبحها
لرسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ليش يذبحها
عشان
عشان يشمله الدعاء
‏him الله feed who feeds me knowsw
the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم the
companions never
in over 20 years ever witnessed him make
a publiccept
it was
answered to the letter
was he said so got
‏and
go propended
prop
so would
feed
‏milk
you
drink man milk and now and you don't
tell him you don't ask him and now
you're going to kill his goat right
they're not his goat he's going to kill
now he say so when I arrived at those
goats
فاذا هي حافله يعني ضروعها
مليئه بالحليب باللبن
واذا هن حفل كلهن
فعمدت الى اناء لال محمد صلى الله عليه
وسلم ما كانوا يطمعون ان يحتلبوا فيه قال
فحلبت فيه حتى علته رغوه فجئت الى رسول
الله صلى
‏said
I looked at their and swen milk
he said so I took a
prop
and all have never seen before and so I
to
‏prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
صلى الله عليه وسلم
المقداد
first question was worrying aboutق
[Silence]
اشربتم شرابكم الليله
قال فقلت يا رسول الله اشرب فشرب
ثم ناولني فقلت يا رسول الله اشرب قال
فشربت ثم ناولني
[Silence]
صلى الله عليه وسلم
قال فلما عرفت ان النبي صلى الله عليه
وسلم قد روي واصبت دعوته ضحكت
القيت الى
‏in
out of you know kind
that people have veryed
I to
down on the on my back of
صلى الله عليه وسلم
فقال النبي صلى الله عليه وسلم احدى
سوءاتك يا مقداد
مقداد
فقلت يا رسول الله كان من امري كذا وكذا
وفعلت كذا
and
what would your be we in we're in a
famon
‏No has anything to
you with me
you don't you don't just give me half of
your por and you got wies to take care
of by the way at the time they would be
about
but youve got a lot of responsibili
and you share with me the only portion
you have and then I tell well actually I
drank your por I went to butcher
‏goats and the human being naturally
will gra
صلى الله عليه وسلم
ما هذه الا رحمه الله
افلا كنت اذنتني فنوقظ
صاحبنا فيصيبا منها
قال فقلت والذي بعثك بالحق
ما ابالي اذا اصبتها واصبتها معك
من اصابها من الناس
merah
you told me so woken up two sleeping
your other two companions so that they
would
اللهink
صلى الله عليه وسلم
this
قل انما انا بشر مثلكم يوحى الي
[Silence]
لا اله الا الله
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يرحمنا اجمعين
نساله تعالى ان يجعلنا ممن يستمعون القول
فيتبعون احسنه والله اعلم وصلى الله وسلم
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله واصحابه اجمعين
والحمد لله رب العالمين جزاكم